M president dear Roberta Mr President de
sh honorable
members much of the attention around the
special European Council has indeed
focused on our 50 billion Euro Ukraine
facility and rightly so we are providing
Ukraine not only with the funding to
keep the economy running but also with a
strong predictability for the next four
years this Parliament has backed our
proposal from the very beginning and
today I would like to thank you for your
unwavering
support this is what it means to stand
with Ukraine for as long as it takes and
with your approval we will be able to
make important payments to Ukraine as
early as
March as we will discuss Ukraine in the
next debate allow me to focus on other
topics of the special European Council
the special European Council also agreed
on the first ever and I emphasize first
ever revision of our multiannual
budget it confirmed the
priorities that the commission presented
back in June and I'm very satisfied that
we got 80% of the funding we had asked
for we had certainly some difficult
choices to make but we have a very good
result now we will now be able to step
up our fight against irregular migration
and better protect our external borders
we now have the means to engage even
more with the countries of the Southern
neighborhood and I'm very glad that the
growth plan for the Western Balkans is
now on a solid solid financing foot we
will also be able to improve our
response to natural disasters in member
states and to humanitarian crisis such
as Gaza and with step we will support
critical technologies that are made in
Europe with this agreement Europe has
the financial resources to tackle some
of the main challenges of this decade
and I would like to thank the European
Parliament for your support so far and
of course I count on your
agreement honorable
members while the European Council was
in session Farmers from AC across Europe
were taking to the
streets many of them feel pushed into a
corner farmers are the first in light in
line feeling the effects of climate
change droughts and floods have
destroyed the Harvest and threaten their
livestocks farmers are feeling the
impact of the Russian war inflation the
rising costs of energy the rising cost
of
fertilizers nevertheless they work hard
every day to to produce the quality food
we eat and for this I think we owe them
appreciations and thanks and
respect and it is true issues have
escalated in recent years our Farmers
deserve to be listened to I know that
they are worried about the future of
Agriculture and about their their future
as
farmers but they also know that
agriculture needs to move to a more
sustainable model of production so that
their Farms remain profitable in the
years to
come and we want to make sure that in
this process the farmers remain in the
driving seat and this is why we launched
the Strategic Dialogue on the future of
Agriculture and the European Union we
have invited a broad scope of
Representatives of the the farming
sectors the young Farmers the rural
communities the seed and fertilizer
industry the food sector the processing
sector but also the financial sector The
Cooperative banking sector the consumers
and environmental groups and of course
science we need to analyze the situation
together to share ideas and most
importantly to develop scenarios for the
future we need to move Beyond a
polarized debate and to create trust
trust is the crucial basis for viable
Solutions and there is a lot at stake
for all of us our European food
production system is
unique the products in our supermarkets
reflect the variety of our cultures and
traditions Europe has the healthiest and
the highest quality food in the world
thanks to our farmers
and they play a central role in this
system and of course they must be paid
fairly for that and it is true that we
provide huge support to this sector our
common agricultural policy is supported
massively by the EU
budget money is important but it is not
everything healthy natural resources are
also key key to maintaining high yields
and in particular fertile Souls has
always been the backbone of our Farmers
livelihood and we know that 60 to 70% of
soils in Europe are now in poor
condition we can reverse these Trends
and many farmers are precisely doing
that but we need to do more now
effective nature protection must offer
generous generous incentives for
intervening Farmers need a worthwhile
business case for nature enhancing
measures perhaps we have not made that
case
convincingly a real incentive that goes
beyond mere loss of yields is
required public subsidies can provide
those incentives and for example premium
labeling in cooperation with retail ERS
and
processors in other words nature
conservation can only be successful
through a bottom up and incentive based
approach because only if our farmers can
live off their land will they invest in
the future and only if we achieve our
climate and environmental goals together
will Farmers be able to continue to make
a living our farmers are well aware of
this and we should Place more trust in
them and let me give you one
example the commission proposed Sur
which is the worthy aim to reduce the
risks of chemical plant production
products but the SE proposal has become
a symbol of
polarization it has been rejected by the
European
Parliament there is no progress anymore
in the council
either so we have to do something and
that is why I will propose to the
college to withdraw this proposal but of
course the topic
stays and to move
forward and to move forward more
dialogue and a different approach is
needed and on this basis the commission
could make a new proposal with much more
matur matured content and with the
stakeholders
together honorable
members the months ahead will not be
easy but I think we have an important
opportunity now it is clear to everyone
in this house that our Agri food sectors
beginning with the Farms needs a
long-term Prospect and the willingness
to listen to each other and to look for
common Solutions we need to avoid the
blame game and to find solutions for
problems
together the report from the Strategic
dialogue of the future of agriculture in
the European
Union is to be tabled by late summer and
it will be enormously important the
results and the recommendations from
this dialogue will be discussed in
Parliament and with the member states
and they will form the foundation of our
future agricultural policy thank you for
your
attention thank you I give the floor now
on behalf of the EP group to the
chairman manred
Weber Madam president of European
Parliament president of the European
Commission